this is everything i dreamed it to be
you having a good time
yeah i can taste blood this is great
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by thundercat
he's a grammy award-winning funk jazz
virtuoso his latest album it is what it
is is available now and today he has his
long overdue tryst with the hot ones
gauntlet
thundercat welcome to the show yeah
i know that you're an adventurous eater
how are you around the spicy stuff
oh man i like feeling like it's the end
of the world i guess usually
definitely like living on the edge
oh this is really awesome cheers man
cheers
hmm little garlicky oh yeah
garlic fresh no addition
so for fans and critics defining your
style has become somewhat of a
contortionist sport
a dose of 70s jazz funk fusion with
flavors of hip-hop
r b soul and electronica mixed in i once
heard a musician
say the interesting thing about music is
its mixing of the predictable
and the unpredictable maybe you don't
even think about this but if you do i am
curious
how do you think about toeing the line
between the familiar and the novel
i think that's kind of like our job as
instrumentalist to a major degree it's
like to
to find those places you know it's like
uh you have to pull from so many
different things
i think after spending a lot of time
with it it kind of develops a voice to a
certain degree so it's like
it's rather i think it's rather
imperative to try to find the lines to
tie and
things together like that yeah it plays
a major role in
your ability to comprehend and move
ahead in
um and knowing what you're able to do
throughout different things sonically
and stuff like that you know
the movie whiplash highlighted the
intensely competitive and isolating
experience of making jazz music
did the depiction of that pressure
cooker environment did you relate to
that
at all as somebody making music at a
young age
i think the best thing ever is watching
an actual drummer's reaction to whiplash
and like
it's like it's like it's everything that
they aren't
most of the time so it's just just
genuine like man [ __ ] that movie
like one of my favorite ones ever is
like jd beck is like one of my you know
he's a good friend he's a younger cat
and he's kind of up and coming and
i would like to imagine somebody
throwing a pen at jd or like my older
brother
you may get hit back with a drum or
something drummers are like kind of
primitive every night and you get like
fred flintstone and
barney rubble over there so yeah no no
not over here on base no we just have
fun bass players
i feel like the whole idea is that it's
it's actually
quite the opposite i feel like everybody
just sleeps with the bass player
i knew you'd like that one yeah
really nice so with the possible
exception of t-pain you're the most
cartoon-obsessed artist i think that
i've ever met in my life and i thought
that your gochi gang appearance was
really interesting particularly the
conversation around anime's recent
coalescing with pop music
what are some of the standout ways that
you've seen anime's influence on the
music industry at large
grow or evolve over say the last decade
like i mean like literally like little
uzi's last like one of his last songs
was sasuke you know it's like
it's getting pretty blatant at this
point yeah it's like
you don't have to hide it as much i feel
like back when i was younger
it was one of those things where i it
was more like a nerdy thing where it's
like you know
everybody your parents your girlfriend
is kind of like what are you talking
about
i think one of my favorite things ever
is knowing that megan the stallion is
like an anime nerd so it's like we're
all winning right now like
all the anime nerds are up right now bro
it's cool man
is someone whose only real job was
working the counter at a comic book
store
what's the most underrated manga in your
opinion the most
underrated underrated
berserk berserk berserk is a
pretty pretty volatile and pretty crazy
and you know it's like
i feel like a lot of people haven't got
a chance to see where that came from so
yeah berserk would be one of those ones
pound for pound what do you think is the
all-time best cartoon theme song
oh that it goes between two for me
there's two
and actually three there's three three
it's hard three
it's hard one is goof troop the goof
troop theme song is like
epic the mighty orbots which was like
this 80s one
some moments in this stuff you could
just tell that they wanted it to be so
amazing so yeah mighty orbots
the goof troop oh chippendale rescue
rangers
when you listen you like i don't know
what it is that i like about it it's
like oh it's because you like all the
modulations and the different
progressions that are happening there
you just can't you can't pinpoint it but
it's like it's
it's like it sounds like michael franks
wrote it or something like that you know
it's like some really intense changes
all right shaquanda's i was looking at
this one earlier too guys next time i'm
going to douse it i don't care
damn this whole table's going to be
covered in sauce
there you go um
right away i like that
that's good of all the musical
instruments that you own is there one
that you'd consider your holy grail like
one that has more sentimental value
than the rest is it that original ibanez
it's a base that was handmade for me by
mike tobias when i was like a teenager
and it's like you could see a person's
reaction it's like whoa wait and they
have to start turning knobs and trying
to figure out what to do because it's
like extremely powerful
and every once in a while in the studio
i have a moment with somebody like man
that base is awesome like yeah this is
this is the one
you know it's like this is the one you
know so and it's like it kind of stays
with me everywhere and stuff too
oh sometimes i'll talk to professional
musicians who say that they have a hard
time winning over
curmudgeonly guitar center employees do
basis
ever have to deal with that same kind of
like
in-store street credit test oh yeah no
it exists it definitely exists you know
but um i think there's i don't think
there's anything wrong with a little bit
of
you know that healthy likes competitive
spirit in certain respects you know it's
like
art inspires art but yeah no i
definitely have my fair share of getting
called a guitar player or like
you know that's not a bass it's got
basses have four strings and it's just
like well that's why
you work at the store and i'm the one on
stage it's like
yeah you don't want to get into a
serious battle with that stuff because
like you know they may go out and slash
your tires at the end of it
here we go goat sauce
i like that kind of sweet
a little more like uh smokey and
barbecue-ish compared to
the other ones i like when it's got a
little sweetness to it like that you
know
nice good setup for the for the burn i
mean you know i like that
so you've described yourself in earnest
as being the same person now as you were
when you were a kid which so far with
this interview story checks out
will keep the theme going on this wing
as a lifelong video game junkie turned
musician
how important is a game's soundtrack to
the overall gaming experience to you
that isn't a that is that question right
there sir
that it is so
so important like super mario and zelda
contra or like sonic the hedgehog it's
one of those things that's like
the note choices and stuff like that
they're so important in certain moments
you know and i don't think they should i
don't ever think they should be washed
over in just
the nuances of how we do stuff now where
it's like it could be cool
but that's what makes a video game
amazing this last mario kart was
fantastic
soundtrack was amazing it's what will
keep you there it'll keep your mind
ticking in the way that it should be i
think halo you know like halo soundtrack
has always been ridiculous you know
i've heard you talk about halo's
soundtrack and describe it as absurdly
amazing like what makes the halo
soundtrack absurdly amazing to you
the composition the orchestration you
know i mean everything from the intro to
like the moments where they're having
the talks and stuff like that
it just feels good like the movement of
the of the the
the different progressions and stuff
like that it fits and it just it's
a perfect taste of what the game is you
know your song flir
ultra it sounds almost like something
that you'd hear in time splitters or
dynasty warriors is that video game
color that i hear in your art
is that intentional or is that just
something i'm hearing oh it's definitely
all part of the dna man at this point
like i remember um
there's been a couple of times where
i'll even talk about it where it's like
me and my brother would fight over the
tv when we were younger because
he wouldn't want to watch the zildjian
drum day video
and i would have sonic the hedgehog
sitting on like without the without it
on pause
and he would think that i was just kind
of like sitting there like but it was
like
i was listening to the music that was
happening because it was it would feed
into that part of my brain that was
processing melody and harmony a lot of
the time
it's all intertwined in the way i
process melody and harmony and stuff
like that like i still listen to my old
video game soundtracks
you know sonic the hedgehog 3 that's
like the hardest soundtrack to find in
the world i don't even think they made a
print of that but like
yeah i still like this is still a big
part of my my processing
this is you guys sauce right here let's
go
um
i like this you're not just saying that
no i'm serious this is good man this is
real good
i just got a vibe man all right
thundercat we have a recurring segment
on our show called explain that gram
where we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so i'll show you the
picture
you just tell us the bigger story first
things first
naked jam session with mac demarco
was this his idea or yours
it was like middle of the tour i think
we were in texas it was hot i don't know
it was just i think anderson was on
stage and we contemplated going out on
stage naked
but uh yeah i just it felt like the
right time we just sat there and it was
like
you know pulled the guitars out and i
was like oh man this is great you know
what make this even better
just getting butt naked and i was like
that's not a bad idea
and the best part i think we were
sitting next to a trash can so it was
like
two naked bums playing but it was fun it
was fun as hell you know it's just we
sat there for about an hour just
talking about life naked you know i
think he had his hat on
what stands out to you when you think
about meeting stevie wonder i think this
is at dave chappelle's dayton benefit
last year that was a genuinely awesome
moment
they hand him a mic you know and i don't
think people i don't think they don't
think people fully realize he's in the
room yet
so we start playing all i do while we're
playing all i do
you know he starts going into the song
dude but you know it's like everybody's
turning up so it's like he literally
just changed the lyrics to like keep on
talking [ __ ]
and i was like what the hell i was like
i looked at my brother i was like yo
stevie is going off right now
again another one of the better moments
in life where it's just like you know
realizing stevie wonder is
a black man from detroit
yeah oh he's surprised if he always had
the pistol on him you know i'm saying
little vinegary so you get a lot of dude
credit for your music but one thing that
i think goes a little bit under the
radar but shouldn't be understated is
many of your songs are quite funny
let me ask you this as someone with a
foot in both worlds
can you give me a musician who you think
could make it as a professional comedian
and then a professional comedian who you
think could make it as a professional
musician
okay immediately there's two people that
come to mind
two musicians i i always got i feel like
i always got to add an extra one to it
like it
one for sure is erica badu
she's like bugs bunny like she's just
out to lunch
she's like comedy and the other one that
comes to mind
and i know we all i feel like we all
would definitely agree with this is
vince staples
vince staples is absurdity incarnate to
this day i have yet to find somebody
that has that amount of observation
you know dave plays piano he doesn't
talk about it like you know
one of his favorite things to play is
like around midnight
so i'm always like anytime he comes in
the room i'll you know try to
nudge him into getting into it because i
know his mind's there and he's like stop
he's always singing he's always got a
tune but
yeah no i mean there's many examples
like one of my favorite ones ever is
like chevy chase
like i don't know if you know you know
his piano skills and singing are like
stellar you know what i mean it's like
he's an amazing pianist musician
or jeff goldblum with the keys you know
he can rip you know
for real you know i mean everybody knows
the steve martin moment you know he's
like you know he's a banjo out of his
you know it's a cool dance man
it's nice to see that you know
this looks like it's gonna be bomb too
i'm ready let's go
okay mm-hmm that's nice
it's still at a comfortable level for
you i love it it's pretty good
i wish your consistency was a little
thicker
yeah that's how you wind up with a hot
sauce for cologne
it's uh but it's all loose like that you
just
accidentally get it on your neck ah i
smell like bourbon habanero ghost pepper
so as i understand it the only real job
that you've ever had was working the
counter at a comic book shop
where you were paid half of your wages
and store credit
now that you're on to more lucrative
endeavors what is like the rarest
or most expensive piece of superhero
memorabilia that you've added to the
shelf
ooh it's either the first appearance of
iron man
or the first appearance of the
incredible hulk you kind of wind up
having to do battle for pieces like that
it's a different type of investment for
sure not everybody notices it you know
because it just looks like a wall full
of comics and stuff like that
like you know like but every night
against somebody be like wait a minute
is that the first event it's like that's
the first appearance
you know and then as a marvel obsessive
what do you think of the
mcu movies are you into those or is it
more just about the comics for
thundercat
i have my feelings i have my ups and
downs about it you know it's like
they do a lot of meshing of weird parts
of the comics together you know i think
i did have my qualms with like you know
avengers infinity war
we're a silver surfer like seriously
where's galactus
nothing i don't get any of that all
right cool the sequencing that they have
with like the fights and stuff like that
like that's
that's like chef's kiss is like i watch
the marvel universe movies
to watch those fights they that's i
couldn't see them played out any better
than the way they do that
big shout out to disney for doing that
because
that is the saving grace i feel like a
lot of these stories when you get to see
him fight you see iron man fight and
you know i mean like thor you know like
it's it's everything captain of captain
america and black panther the way they
show that stuff i love it i love it man
i genuinely love it
it's that part where i have to go to the
hospital
yep
i like that
i recognize that pain yeah
me too all too well it's going right
along with this year
ride along fits right in there feels
like eating nail polish
i make a baby i'm hiccupping all
you hiccuping i make a beat
this is reminding me this is all taking
me back to two years ago
this is horrible but uh it's all right
so is everything
i hope i stop i don't think i've ever
started hiccuping
huh i don't think i've ever started
hiccuping
during one of these and now here i am
hiccuping but i'll try to get through
this
i'm a pro no that's fantastic one of
your early gigs was playing alongside
suicidal tendencies which is one of the
seminal american hard rock punk groups
what were the pros and cons of coming of
age
in that environment as a teenager
you know anything from getting hit in
the head on stage with a beer bottle to
you know finding love of your life in
the bathroom stall uh
i don't know man like i think it was all
awesome
other than erica but i do i don't think
i've ever worked with anybody that
supported me more than mike mir
i feel like i learned so much from mike
and dean and mike
and one of my favorite shows ever one of
my favorite shows ever was one of the
last shows i did with suicidal
and it was in uh south america
and the lineup was literally um
mars volta suicidal and rage against the
machine
and there's no it's not a festival it's
just the three bands
i remember feeling like i felt like i
was a part of something
um that's gonna go through me like a ton
of knives
i can feel it i can feel it my booty
hole is going to
it's going to kick my ass
my booty hole is going to kick my ass
that's okay though because
it's not okay
this is proof that i need therapy yeah
well after are you gonna start coughing
man i know i just i caught a pepper
i did you just made me laugh and i
caught a pepper flake in the back of my
throat it was like
uh-huh eyes popping out of my head and
[ __ ] all right here we go
oh yeah
ah this is awesome
you know this is just awesome this is
this is everything i dreamed it to be
you having a good time yeah i can taste
blood this is great
i like that after the bomb too
i think everything's a vacation after
the bomb
but it kind of complements the real
garlic
the real peppery and garlic thing that
the bomb is doing it only adds a little
bit of sweetness to it
you really get that pepper it's almost
like a bitter apple or something
yeah yeah not too sweet but just like
ever so slightly sweet
just a smidget sweet smidget smidget
sweet
tiniest tiniest of sweetness so i'm
intrigued by what seems to be a
deep and abiding love for bowling even
reading in an interview you described
bowling's zen
qualities what elevates bowling to a
spiritual dimension for you
it started with austin me and austin
used to sit and watch the big lebowski
and i'm by austin i'm talking about
austin peralta he's like a
fellow brain feeder artist and died at
an early age
we always used to argue about who was
jeffrey lebowski and who was
walter and when he passed it kind of
like i felt like it became something for
me to keep
connected to who we were you know so i
would just go bowling by myself a lot
you know like i'd go bowl when the kids
were bowling you know or like just hang
out at the bowling alley and then
i look up and it became a bit of a
normal thing for me you know me and mac
would go bowling every now and again and
stuff
you know somewhere in there for me it
became a bit of peace
again the big lebowski is like
everything
to me you know it's like it's it reminds
me everything isn't so terrible
you know
ooh you know when they put gold on it
means it's a
i don't know what gold means anymore
it makes fart noises thundercat what a
ride it's been
yeah man cheers yeah
cheers
whoa
that's different
very round speaking of round
thundercat i want to take things
completely
full circle here on wing 10 because i
don't know if you remember this
do you remember remember the first time
we met it was at the comedy store
backstage do you remember that you were
rolling with hannibal
was bill burr performing that night too
bill yep bill burr performed that night
as quite the line up i think like tom
segura was the headliner but then
at the comedy store it's funny because
people can just start popping in
yeah cause hannibal just he just walked
in there he did a little 15 minutes or
something like that too
right melanie camacho i think was there
too or something like that
but what stands out to me about that
night is when i met you you were like
hey dude guess what i just did the hot
ones lineup
as a way to pre-game for a concert and i
just kept running it back
and running it back and running it back
and as i understand it
as i understand it you had some problems
you were maybe
not careful around the eyes all the time
i've heard that there might have been a
cross-pollination issue with your
butthole even
so if you could now that you've taken on
the hot ones gauntlet for real
what do you remember about that first
experience
okay i think this has got to be again
one of the funnier moments in life for
sure
me and zack fox get all hyped up like
beavis and butthead well you just do
you know we've seen some of this stuff
we figured he'd kick it up a notch
so we got like the uh the 5 million
and the 9 million scoville mad dog you
know
and i remember seeing zach like running
around in circles like an episode of ren
and stimpy
and he's screaming at the top of his
lungs like knocking [ __ ] over like a
like a scared cat he's just like
kicking statues over he's just like
running he's sweating he's like i can
see the lining around the dust in the
house
you know i think i farted and then my
butt started itching
when i got that 5 million pepper sauce
in my [ __ ]
i was like this is either how love real
true love feels
or this is like the edge of death so i'm
like you know everything from scratching
my eyes
it's like i've spread it everywhere at
this point like it's like i didn't
scratch my eyes i remember i scratched
my balls at one point
and zach is completely almost
incapacitated in a whole nother room
and so i'm like yo zack you know we're
going to be late for the yg concert
i had went through the whole concert
with a booty hole feeling like somebody
just
gave me old flamethrower to the ass well
i'm happy that you
survived and i'm happy that you survived
today's
gauntlet look at you thundercat taking
on
hot ones this time on camera
and for real and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you my friend
this camera or this camera or whatever
you have
going on at that great replica set by
the way i i've failed to mention but
like it's
it looks like you're here in the studio
almost let the people know what you have
going on in your life
what i have going on in my life it's a
slow process of getting back into it
it's been very emotional ride
but i am working on some new music
and farting and not saying excuse me and
you know having awkward conversations in
elevators
great job great job
hey
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
episode and i have a very exciting
announcement
we are in the honey game baby say hello
to hot ones
nugget honey our sweetest spice yet it's
perfect on wings
perfect for dessert perfect in cocktails
perfect on pizza
let me tell you how we make it we take
american craft gin made in vermont with
raw honey then infuse it with just the
right amount of pepper x
then we blend that spicy gin and
american alfalfa honey a delicate
delicious honey that comes from the wind
river valley of wyoming
until we finally have a honey that's
delicious
with just the right amount of kick if
you want to get your hands on the hot
ones nugget honey
november 19th november 19th november
19th at heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to order
it's sweet it's delicious it's spicy
i say [ __ ] it get two